there's a little bit of nervousness even
in a physical space like this Oh am I
going to run into someone am I gonna
have an argument there's an atmosphere
of oh man I wish this all would go away
I don't want to talk about it I don't
want to speak out about it because
otherwise I might get caught up in her
ass as well there were some events where
there's really mild harassment and
stalking and questions like are you
really a gamer what do you do do you
even want to be in games like are you HR
why do you assume that that's what I do
and not something in development a lot
of women and games were speaking out
well before gamergate became a thing and
so i really see the the moment that
gamergate catalyzed as being a reaction
to this slow Todd that's been building
and building over many years but now
that this backlash has emerged and it's
become clear that this is going to be a
struggle I do see institutions taking
the opportunity to speak out and say
something they're realizing that maybe
we created this culture or what least
had a hand in it so maybe we should try
and undo it so even though there's a
great downside to that with people
feeling afraid or like they're being
watched there also isn't upside that
that people are galvanized to actually
speak out for what they believe in
what do you get when you take a
community of gamers a conspiracy theory
about the media and a bunch of
misogynistic attention-seeking trolls
the hashtag gamergate